CNN is under fire after it refused to
retract a breaking news story on
collusion between Donald Trump and
Russia has despite the news channels
source publicly withdrawing a
significant claim the whole story was
based on while here in the studio with
me is artis Elia Petrenko to give us
some more details on this how does this
work exactly why has the network been
standing by the story well Nicky this is
a special one and I'm here to share with
you some of my observations for how
things are done when it comes to some
media organizations across the Atlantic
as you've said CNN in particular we've
gotten used to the media sometimes
running sensational stories because a
number of anonymous sources tell them
this or that but my question to you is
what if the anonymous source reveals his
identity and says that his story is not
true or that he has made several
mistakes perhaps you will expect these
people to take a step back maybe
consider some skepticism publish a
correction or take the story down
altogether
not if you're CNN sources with knowledge
tell myself and Carl that Michael Cohen
claims that then candidate Donald Trump
knew in advance about the June 2016
meeting in Trump Tower crucially these
sources tell us that Cohen is willing to
make that assertion to the special
counsel robert muller so Nicki this was
part of their original story from a
month ago and back then the sensation
was that Donald Trump's former lawyer
according to CNN will definitely tell
the investigators that mr. Trump had
known about this infamous infamous re
Trump Tower said down featuring his son
and the Russian it counted for a
sensation because many people in that
case would see this as solid evidence
that the collusion had taken place and a
few weeks later the man called Lanny
Davis who is the attorney of my
Koen he comes out and says that he was
actually the source of CNN that's a then
B he's made a mistake and C his insight
into the story is of course very tricky
was misinterpreted and he eventually
even went on-air he went to one of the
CNN studios to tell people that the
reporting of this story got mixed up so
Michael Cohen does not have information
that President Trump knew about the
Trump Tower meeting with the Russians
beforehand or you know it is not oh
that's fascinating isn't it how CNN
taken any steps to defend its position
after this well I'll tell you that CNN
first of all did nothing to warn their
viewers that the story could have been
false in fact they even began attacking
the man who was their own source
initially they kept blaming him for
changing his mind like the wind has
there been any reaction from other US
journalists in response to this well
other influential media the likes of New
York Times in Washington posed by the
way these guys broke the news story
after CNN when the new circumstances
were revealed they at least cast some
sort of doubt over it what they did was
they published some sort of editors
notes or follow-up reports they didn't
say the story was false all altogether
but again at least casting some sort of
doubt counts here and that was the point
when journalists went to CNN for comment
all CNN said was we stand by the story
we still think it is true and it's still
right because apparently they had
multiple sources the question is did
they reveal any of these sources no did
they cast at least some glimmer of doubt
over it no that's fascinating thank you
for bringing us that story today that's
not easily petrenko
you